[Music]
[Applause]
Westwood One CBS Sports NFL college
football analyst the former NFL
offensive lineman and host of the Ross
Tucker football podcast Ross back on the
program Ross uh should Jerry Jones have
told Mike McCarthy and or Dak Prescott
that he was trading for trade lands
no I don't I don't think he really needs
to do that I mean now the Mike McCarthy
part I think obviously McCarthy should
be part of those discussions and I think
that's very interesting you know that it
doesn't sound like he was overly
involved in those I think that's telling
for the Cowboys organization and how
they work and how it's always worked
quite frankly and probably says
something about McCarthy's status there
in Dallas which I think a lot of people
think is probably tenuous coming into
this year but that's how the Cowboys run
their organization they felt like there
was value in getting Trey Lance they
want to get a Young quarterback that if
something happens the DAC can go in and
make some plays and also start to
develop someone behind that because I
think they know that deck you know they
want them there they're going to try to
do everything they can to keep them
there but based on what they did with
the last contract and how they butchered
his contract the last time Dan in the
situation they know that Dak has crazy
leverage to get even more money in his
next deal
how does this work out for Trey lands
well I think it's really strange that he
went to the Cowboys you know if you're
the Niners you don't care right I mean
you're gonna get as much as you can and
I think that I I guess where the Niners
said they were surprised they got a
fourth round pick because you have to
guarantee the over five million dollars
that he's making in 2024. I'm just
surprised I think Dan that none of these
other teams whether it's the Vikings or
whoever you know even teams that maybe
have quarterback concerns the Broncos
you know frizzy's Bronco maybe the
Raiders although ain't no kind of looked
really good I guess I'm surprised that
none of these other teams that might go
with young quarterbacks or might have
quarterback situations even like the
commanders right like why wouldn't the
commanders Bring In Trey Lance in case
Sam Hal falters I'm a little surprised
that the Cowboys a team with an
established quarterback was willing to
give up more than any other teams were
yeah and Dallas has two better
quarterback and three better
quarterbacks Dak Will Greer and Cooper
Rush are better than Trey Lance one of
those is probably going to get cut
because I don't think you make a deal
like this for a fourth round pick and
then can you keep four quarterbacks
somewhere can you put one on the
practice squad or is it you get three
quarterbacks you can put on the roster
well so I think that's what they're
going to do I think they'll cut Will
Greer and they'll put him on the
practice squad would be my guess okay I
don't know if Will gets picked up
elsewhere he's bounced around decent
amount you know there's other teams that
have quarterbacks they like as well but
I actually think Dan that that was the
sense I got just seeing some Dak quotes
and his body language I think Dak was a
little bit frustrated about that part of
it you know Will Greer goes out there
and has like the game of his life he's
probably not gonna matter although it
always matters right because if they do
try to put him on practice squad Greer
going out there and playing that well
does give him a chance to get picked up
somewhere else I do think it's funny too
Dan that the 49ers didn't just keep Trey
Lance as their third guy I mean they're
the ones that helped get this new rule
so you can have three quarterbacks suit
up on game day because of what happened
in the NFC Championship Game and yet
they still didn't think Trey Lance was
even value enough to be number three
I'm not even sure that they think Trey
Lance is better than Brandon Allen and I
think they thought it would be better
for Purdy in the entire organization to
just move move away from him in part
ways can you be a bust at 23.
I think you can be a bust
from a 49ers perspective and for 49ers
fans the real difficulty now Dan is I
don't know if he's ever gonna really
get that chance you know he's under
contract with Dallas for two more years
now this year and next year when does
trailer I hope he gets another shot to
actually start or play I mean Dan they
thought enough of him last year that he
was a starter last year remember when
Jimmy Garoppolo wasn't even allowed to
go to practices or anything Jimmy was
like on his own field because the Niners
said we are going to live with the
Growing Pains of Trey Lance he's going
to play we like them and now he's in a
situation where I don't know when he
gets a chance to play again but I think
we'd all like to just give give the kid
a year I mean when does a guy get
drafted that high and he doesn't even
get a year and the answer is Trey Lance
because he got hurt but I would love to
see somebody somewhere give the kid a
year to play and see what he can do it's
hard to say he's a bust when he's barely
even played yeah but we've seen these uh
Reclamation projects where Gino's Smith
ends up with Seattle uh you know the
Ryan Tannehill ends up with Tennessee
you know these guys eventually have that
opportunity a second or third time
around and at age 23 if he has the
talent I I just I think we got caught up
in North Dakota State talent and
thinking oh he can be just like Carson
Wentz or Easton stick or whatever it
might well he had to be better than
Eastern stick they gave up too much but
you know he was great for a great team
and it just didn't I and I said this
first hour if you can't be a good
quarterback in Kyle Shanahan system then
I have some real questions about that
because he Kyle Shanahan's the
quarterback of the 49ers somebody goes
out there and just you know has to hand
off and occasionally throw a pass well
and the the concerning part then is when
you watched him this preseason
there's like wide open throws that I've
had multiple people tell me on my show
that's the read in that offense like you
throw it to that guy and for whatever
reason only Trey Lance can answer he
wouldn't throw it to that guy so uh I I
think from that perspective he probably
is a bust if he doesn't correct that
doesn't get a chance to play I do hope
though that he gets to Tana Hill Gino
Smith chance I hope he makes the most of
it Ross Tucker Westwood won CBS Sports
NFL college football analyst and uh
let's see he had Hawaii Vandy week zero
for Westwood one and then coming up this
weekend Oregon State San Jose State
for CBS right really looking forward to
it you know that's Oregon State top 20
in the country and that's where DJ
ungele went that's where the former
Clemson quarterback is so I'm looking
for and and San Jose State Chevron
Cordero is the preseason Mountain West
offensive player of the year so should
be awesome I don't think Dan how many of
your listeners right now know that
Oregon State won 10 games last year and
finished in the top 20. I don't know why
and maybe that's part of the pac-12's
problem but
nobody knows him yeah they all know now
right you just told him yeah now now
everybody knows that all right give me
the NFL team okay
Colt's going with the rookie
Carolina's going with the rookie Texans
going with the rookie
rank the decisions by those three teams
on is it the right decision to go with
the rookie quarterback
well
I think
the interesting one to me I guess is
Carolina just because they have a pretty
capable guy in Andy Dalton I would say
he's the best of the backups when you
compare him to minshu and indie or Davis
Mills and Houston but they were pretty
clear right when they drafted Bryce
young it's really interesting isn't it
Dan like all these teams it was pretty
obvious
almost as soon as they drafted him but
Jim irsay said you got to play which is
why I never understood what that why
they were even splitting the Reps in
Indy you know you talk about some of
these organizations and who's in charge
then they're splitting the Reps the
first team reps in Indy Jim irsay had
said like a month ago that Richardson
needed to play he needed to learn on the
job and it's very clear that ursay runs
that organization in every way so I
would say they all are doing the right
decision by playing these young guys I
think Bryce young will probably fare the
best to start out but I'm a little bit
concerned about that Carolina offensive
line I mean they looked bad especially
Vicky left tackle in the preseason
uh does it matter what your pre-season
record is when the regular season starts
no literally nobody ever talks about a
preseason game again once the regular
season starts unless someone got injured
in that game or else the Baltimore
Ravens streak I mean I played Seven
Years I don't ever remember anyone
referencing the preseason in any way
after that oh I take that back then 2002
I started every preseason game for Steve
Spurrier and Dan I think he thought
those games counted I'm not sure but I
think he thought they counted we were
winning by like 30 points I was starting
I it was so exci I was like this is
amazing we're awesome I'm awesome like
this this is fantastic that is not this
that is not how it worked out did you
have fun like came around did you have
fun with Spurrier
oh dude he was amazing I mean was he a
good coach though
no
terrible how can you be a great college
coach a Hall of Fame college coach
and not at least a good NFL coach
I don't understand
um how he had so much success in college
he must be a heck of a recruiter I don't
think he really wanted I mean Dan
opening night speech before training
camp now keep in mind we had Marty
Schottenheimer the year before the year
before Marty Sean Hammer gave a speech
that the hair stand up on the back of
your neck like you're ready to kill
somebody
spur gets up there and he goes men
I went to 12 of these here training
camps as a player and you know I don't
remember one good thing I ever got out
of it but Mr snedder wants us to be here
so let's try to get something done
tomorrow that was like the start of the
Season speech I gotta tell you one more
quick story yeah
okay yeah Patrick Ramsey's first start
against the New Orleans Saints in 2002
first round pick from Tulane spurrier's
offense does not have hot reads or sight
adjusts so if they bring an extra guy
you're supposed to either audible
beforehand or just make a play
so the Saints look like they're bringing
in Blitz from the left
and Patrick Ramsey doesn't see it and
he's just calling the signals and
Spurrier from the sideline home game
and Ramsay looks over
here
which is a slide to the left and
remember
as soon as he says that the Saints
rotate the safety back on that side the
the safety comes down the other side so
they're blitzing from the other side and
and Springer goes Patrick
Ramsay looks over Ringo slide Rango
slide rims okay okay bring it up delay a
game delay this is the NFL Dan delay
this is the NFL and the head coach is
yelling the quarterback to make the
audibles from the sideline we gotta
delay a game that's when I was very
confident that the Springer thing was
not going to work again that's when I
knew we had some real problems there
uh safe travels you'll be uh there for
Oregon State they won 10 games last year
and uh facing San Jose State good to
talk to you as always Ross likewise you
guys look like yeah a blast last week
Dan that was that was amazing that'd be
like top five things in my life to go on
an Irish uh pub crawl with Will Ferrell
incredible there's always next year Ross
thank you bud see ya Ross Tucker
Westwood won CBS Sports on the call with
Oregon State San Jose State